my name is Seth Jacobites I'm an
assistant professor in the department of
East Asian languages and literature's
it's my great pleasure today to
introduce our invited speaker professor
sabine first up she's a professor in the
department of east asian languages and
cultural studies at University of
California Santa Barbara many of us know
professor first took from her earliest
work on sexology her first book came out
in 2003 entitled colonizing sex sexology
and social control in modern Japan she's
also the author of uneasy warriors
gender memory and popular culture in the
Japanese army which came out in 2007 and
most recently professor Krista was also
the editor and contributor to the book
playing war children and the paradoxes
of modern militarism in Japan which came
out in 2017 and I know many of the other
contributors and it's just a really
fascinating study so I would like to
kind of get right into the talk so we
can give her the opportunity to give the
presentation have plenty of time for
comments without further ado professor
Severus thank you so much a set for this
kind introduction thank you also to the
council for inviting me and for having
me here I haven't been here for quite a
while and I'm happy to see you all even
though I know this is a terribly busy
time of the year for everybody and I
would like to just make one small
correction not substantial but playing
war is actually a monograph it's a
monograph that came out in the same year
as child's play that I co-edited that
Seth meant to mention no I just wanted
to make sure I did realize that it was
sort of not ideal to have two different
things come out
at the same time in any case in 1951
General Douglas MacArthur testified
before the United States Senate that the
support that he supported the protection
of the Emperor's system on the basis
that the Japanese were in a very tuition
Airy condition measured by the standards
of modern civilization they would be
like a boy of 12 susceptible to
following new models new ideas indeed
Imperial Japan's official rhetoric had
been ripe with references to markers of
age including those of the generations
and maturity and even most recently in
the early 2000s the Financial Times in
relation to Japan's self-defense forces
deployment to Iraq questioned Japan's
status as a grown up nation and yet
despite such prevalent references to
Japan's would-be infant ility we have
ascribed low status to the study of
children and childhood according to
historical data provided by the
Statistics Bureau within the Ministry of
Internal Affairs and communications
children defined here as individuals up
to the age of 14 comprised 34 percent of
the total population in 1888 and 36
percent in 1940 and yet we have at least
tacitly assumed that the fleeting status
of childhood the child's liminal
identity justifies ignoring children is
historically relevant altogether for
better or worse children grow up and yet
to the Japanese imperialist state
children or rather very specific notions
of the child and of childhood were
immensely useful it is this use value of
children that I examine in my talk today
in order to shed light on the cultures
of emotions of emotion that were
mobilized and
shaped during the Japanese Empire
Japan's modern nation-state building
came late and rapidly in the second half
of the 19th century during this time the
feudal warrior class gave way to a
conscription based mass army mandatory
elementary schooling was introduced for
boys and girls and eventually the modern
major constitution was promulgated in
1890 Japan's emergence as a formidable
military power in Asia came to rest on
victorious wars against China and Russia
subsequently Japan pursued both what
Jennifer Robertson has called anti
colonial colonialism and the building of
an empire that was eventually
articulated as Greater East Asia
co-prosperity sphere and that in time
included large parts of Asia amidst this
nation and empire building references to
adults often evoke the language and
iconography of difference often
difference in terms of maturity both
when casting Japan is junior to
Westerners not only in physique but also
in the maturity of its civilization and
conversely when casting Japan as senior
as older brother or even father figure
to other agents children and the concept
of childhood by contrast were assigned
the role of erasing distinctions the
boundaries between Japanese colonizers
and colonized Asians and the exact
conditions under which children
encountered soldiers whether in times of
war occupation or peace during the last
three decades of the 19th century the
Japanese political and educational
elites facilitated the complex
historical work of constructing
childhood yet which children had a
childhood and what kind of childhood is
never self-evident data but socially
constructed in the
struggle between the young and the old
in Japan the mandatory elementary school
system introduced in 1870 to reconfigure
childhood and divisions of the child
population in two age groups by
prescribing first five and then six
years of basic education for children
from the age of six that same year the
conscription system deemed that male
adulthood began at the age of twenty
at which time all males took the
military physical exam
note that guidelines regarding when
girls reached adulthood were not
similarly fixed such remained a
designation tied to marriage and
motherhood the fundamental code of
education as well as subsequent
legislation in the area of education
welfare and crime work to gradually
replace class status with age group or
grade level as a primary social marker
during childhood these institutional
changes emerged from and reinforced
social changes and triggered a number of
public debates about childhood about the
links between the health and welfare of
children and the power of the nation and
about the possible benefits to children
of children's rights informed by these
debates legislation also increasingly
codified children's vulnerability
innocence and need of protection
sometimes even from their own parents
the publishing and entertainment
industry's tactics involved the marking
and erasing of race and gender from
representations of children so as to
symbolically contain and enhance your
ins symbolic use value in the
multi-layered
and inherently contradictory imperialist
project starting in 1931 when publishing
and entertainment specialists
volunteered in cooperating with army
propagandists helping to mobilize the
nation behind the military occupation of
Northeast China
children made a powerful appearance in a
range of visual and textual genre they
were featured in illustrations and
increasingly photographs devoted to
representing and commenting on the war
and the armed forces forces such images
were printed in among other media
educational guides children's books and
magazines newspapers soldiers memoirs
child memoirs childhood became a matter
of imagining and of imaging to an
unprecedented degree politically
multivalent child centered images
constituted as cultural strategy that
exploited what I will call their
emotional capital a concept akin to
pierre bourdieu's
trial of economic social and cultural
capital the emotional capital comprised
both distinctly modern understandings of
the emotional makeup of the child and
calculations of adults responses to
children and representations of children
and childhood rather than exploring
emotions in terms of inner and
individual phenomena I'm interested in
emotions as collective cultural
experiences that potentially erode the
economies such as inside outside
individual collective and public private
but how does one study the appropriation
of emotions much as we would approach
historical inquiry by reading between
the lines looking for context
repetitions contradictions points of
agreement and discord by examining the
particular and a group large trends and
individual examples in a range of
textual and visual formats based on such
broad analysis my term emotional capital
aims to capture both the oft-repeated
notion the children were politically
innocent
morally pure and in doubt with authentic
feelings as well as the expectations
that adults would respond to
representations of children with a
predictable set of emotions indeed an
underlying question in this analysis is
just what emotions were offered to the
adults who not only read explained and
contemplated children's books magazines
and games but who also viewed the child
they were reading to against the
prescriptive textual and visual
templates indeed for most of these
materials the historical readers best
understood not as an individual passive
recipient of various forms of
indoctrination and socialization but as
absorbed and enthusiastically reading
exploring her imagination participating
perhaps with other children or adults in
the production of the texts meaning and
exercising various degrees of autonomy
across age cohorts and generations
levels of literacy and to some degree
even class of these expected adult
responses one was essential the
insistence the children need protection
one prevalent debate concerning the
nature of children one one prevalent
debate concerns the nature of children
one camp believed that children are
inherently wild and unpredictable and
thus needed to be trained and controlled
the other conceptualized the child as
humanity at its best at its most natural
and innocent this camp authenticated
children's emotions as inherently
sincere and coming from within
reflecting these tensions child rearing
guides attempted to straddle both camps
by encouraging mothers to carefully
monitor and channel their children's
potentially evil instincts
and turbulent passions until they
evolved into mature well-adjusted people
leave nothing to chance they insisted
least of all the training of children's
emotions indeed children's emotions were
expected to be internal and natural and
yet also to adhere to universal
aesthetic standards of expression guides
for the writing of comfort letters for
instance the jaws did not just expect
young letter writers to express
appropriate emotions it was assumed that
they generally felt those emotions for
instance a slim guide book from 1940
specified that letters by be written
quote with a heart full of deep of deep
emotion and gratitude since soldiers on
a battlefield were far from home and
starved quote true human emotions this
advice further highlighted the
aforementioned paradox of the appeal
though the children's sentiments must
come from deep within must be true and
sincere they also had to be carefully
crafted in order to establish the
desired emotional bond between children
writers and adult combatants and readers
cultural producers held contradictory
notions of just how emotions work on the
one hand they assumed the children's
emotions were individual inner and true
phenomena uncorrupted by the adult world
or at least not yet corrupted on the
other they recognised the utility of
seeing children's emotions as collective
cultural and historical experiences that
were thus open to education and training
as well as to manipulation and
indoctrination this talk then examines
how emotions associated with children
and childhood
functioned as social practices under the
particular conditions of the Asia
Pacific War I argue the children's
emotional capital relied on the
assumption of shared readily available
feelings that might have strengthened a
sense of community as in Barbara Rosen
wines emotional communities more
importantly for my analysis however it
furthered a sense of an imperial unity
of children against the backdrop of
adults and adulthoods
at war as well as of a universality of
childhood both across the Empire and
across the poorest and vulnerable divide
between war occupation and peace
these cultural producers appropriated
children's presumed innocence
vulnerability and purity so as to lend
moral authority to war legitimize Empire
and ultimately naturalize those same
children as future engineers of peace as
such the legitimacy of Japan's
militarism and imperialism came to
symbolically depend on the Empire's
children as well as on the qualities and
capabilities assigned to them in October
1938 the elegant Osaka based lifestyle
photo magazine normal rifle home life
published three photographs by minor
photographer named Yamagami in Tarot
they appeared in a rubric titled
children's military fashion the first is
of a sitting baby it was an oversized
uniform cap and embraces an enormous
pumpkin between its legs in the second a
bare chested boy perhaps eight years old
whereas the military helmet and blows a
Boogle in the third photograph a boy
wearing a military helmet holds a wooden
rifle that sports a Japanese flag
reading soldiers house the caption for
the three photographs describes the boys
as
commanders of our house in all three
photographs the child looks playfully
into the camera laughing these
photographs mirror numerous visual and
narrative representations of children
appropriated indeed commandeered for a
particular cultural complex one that
used emotions and the innate concept
concept of childhood in order to
legitimize Japan's were making and
empire building the swift multiplication
of photographic depictions of children
in military settings had been prompted
by two cultural shifts first family
photography became a widespread hobby
among the urban middle class it also
became popular for families to
commissioned portraits of the children
dressed in military garb in stylized war
settings such portraits made for curious
tableau boys and sometimes girls wildung
toy rifles or bayonets stern-faced at
attention whether at home or
concentrating on rifle practice in
school yards this is actually
kindergarten yard note that such a hobby
called for considerable expense child
sized military uniforms tank-like
strollers toy guns such playthings were
out of reach for the vast majority of
their population but families of lesser
means partook as well I'll bid with a
stick for a rifle and a homemade flag
though some of the portrayed children
appear intensely uncomfortable many
others are smiling and laughing
altogether these portraits are gern a
chiral playful and nonetheless
inevitable transformation the world of
children will in time give way to the
world of war an event reality that
parents and other photographers readily
promoted as for the second cultural
shift during the same period military
photography increasingly complemented
its stock repertoire large troop
formations groups of commanders and
occasionally emperor hirohito
on his white horse with human interest
shots informed by this eras penchant for
social realism in photography notably to
express the emotions of people's lives
these human interest images frequently
featured children with soldiers whether
in Japan in the colonies or even behind
the front lines for instance less than
three months after the Nanking Massacre
the March 2nd 1938 issue of the photo
magazine Asahi Grove the pioneer of
graphic magazines featured a series of
photographs from the Chinese front in
line with contemporaneous military
photography many of the images portray
occupying troops going about ordinary
activities such as setting up tents
cleaning their equipment or taking their
surroundings but one photographic
close-up depicts
smiling very young-looking Japanese
soldier posing with two Chinese girls
just as an older brother might pose with
his sisters for a family album
the smaller girl is even sitting on a
young man's lap the caption states that
upon the Japanese soldiers arrival these
quote picture-perfect lovely bobbed
haired girls cheerfully called out in
Japanese long live the Japanese army and
of course the adorability of the Chinese
children serves to sideline if not make
invisible the extreme violence that the
Japanese army this young man included
had just perpetrated on their community
the girls gender further underlines
their vulnerability as well as the
soldiers role a surrogate older brother
and protector for this maneuver to be
effective illustrators and writers of a
wide range of publications needed to
exaggerate some distinctions and erase
others one distinctions between soldiers
hailed as fearless combatants at
fighting enemies across Asia and
soldiers as momentary surrogate brothers
or even mothers to children in occupied
areas two distinctions between
heteronormative formations of boys and
girls and the pronounce these sexualized
representations of prepubescent children
three distinctions between Japanese and
other Asian children within and beyond
the boundaries of empire and four
distinctions between the relentless mass
violence of the present and the peace
and harmony that the prepubescent child
by virtue of its innocence would bring
to the future the first objective
blurring the law the incongruity of the
soldier held at home as a fearless
competent while also acting a surrogate
protector to children in occupied areas
was affected by the dissemination via
various media of images of children
having curious and friendly encounters
with soldiers these encounters
constituted an emotional formation
images and narratives of children with
soldiers that are relentlessly
reproduced in order to reinforce the
relationship of one to the other
postcards with such motifs were given
away or cheaply sold children's picture
books and magazines included these
manipulations in both illustrations and
advertisements one ad in particularly in
particular vividly depicts this
incongruity
an imperial army soldier offers a
Chinese child a caramel this is this
part of the picture
in the background a Japanese mother in
an apron that indicates her middle class
affiliation gives the same brand of
caramel to her Japanese children the
text reads the clock turns three the
Chinese child received one major caramel
haven't you also received major caramels
from your mother at about this time
Meiji caramels and of course thus text
and drawing like in both the soldier at
the front to the mother at the home
front and Japanese children to Chinese
children and thus to a universality of
children when the November 1933 issue of
the leading boys magazine boys club
features a naturally gifted boy named
Ichiro drawing donkey Chi and his black
mouse friend Sir cutty alongside nor
akuto under the admiring eyes of his
friends the text suggests that the three
comic protagonists a hapless soldier dog
nor akuto a clueless boy king of
cannibals donkey ji and is generally far
wiser Mouse sir Cuddy had actually come
to visit and and ostensibly play with
him a fantasy of many a young boy reader
at the time the fantasy namely of
bringing the Empire home in the shape of
the comical embodiments of child
soldiers the longing for intimate
connections and playful interactions of
Ichiro with these fictional soldiers is
reconfigured many times across a range
of publications typically designed for
children one such drawing in a
children's book evoked an over-the-top
idyllic scene of iga soldiers with
children of occupied territories text
alongside the illustration explained
that the soldiers were about to read to
the native children the
Comfort letters they had just received
from Japanese children the light-skinned
Japanese soldiers lounge under palm
trees leisurely conversing with brown
skin children woman of them a casually
tickles a child's head two soldiers read
the letters out loud just like they
might read to their own children back in
Japan as for the comparison of children
from different countries when Japanese
children were depicted into mingling
with children under Japanese colonial
control most often Korean or Manchurian
the Japanese children were distinguished
from the others only by their clothing
or perhaps the presence of the Hinomaru
yet another variation involved cross
species depictions with fairy tale boys
such as peach boy Momotaro in a range of
critters including mice in one 1936
issue of Yan ncredible children's club
for instance a certain Noguchi you Joe
describes how a mouse commander leads an
advancing army game at the occasion of
New Year's his army of mice dressed as
girls and boys march in one line
Hinomaru flags in paw while making a
train's onomatopoetic hissing sounds
even more ambivalent and ambiguous were
depictions of Japanese and German
children published in both children's
and adult pop locations these formations
appeared in part as the result of the
significant changes in political
attitudes in the years leading up to and
beyond the tripartite pact of 1940 for
instance in as early as 1935 Hitler
stated that quote this S would have to
become the German samurai I'll be within
the Nazi ideology of the Germans being
superior to the Japanese
and yet in 1942 a secret security
service report described the German
populations attitude towards the
Japanese as being consumed by an
inferiority complex likely from the
feats of the quote death-defying
Japanese and the magnitude of their
deliberate and conscious sacrifice all
the same Japanese newspapers and
magazines embraced the notion of
children's universality and unity
extending it to children of the Third
Reich across different publications and
readership generations at least one
picture book here the Kodansha picture
book on Hitler Kodansha no Erin Hydra
claimed that Hitler loved children and
the Germany and Japan were good friends
the book had likely been inspired by a
series of exchanges and mutual visits by
journalists politicians and
representatives of mass organizations of
athletes and Hitler Youth the ostensibly
friendly relationship between the two
nations was succinctly depicted in a
drawing of two nearly identical boys
shaking hands they're the same height
and they both were knee-length black
shorts that the image is in black and
white furthers the racial ambiguity of
their facial features they are
differentiated only by their clothes a
German Hitler Youth uniform and a
Japanese boys school uniform in this
evocative illustration these two boys
signaled equality similarity unity and
the universality of childhood all while
engaged in the distinctly non childish
gesture of a handshake but though Hitler
was frequently photographed with
children and youth for propaganda
purposes but no means was his call to
elevate childhood do gild it with
innocence empathy and
moral purity his often proclaimed love
of children strove to eradicate
childhood by conceptualizing boys and
girls as eager to join the Hitler Youth
and German League of the League of
German girls youth organizations that
offered a tantalizing whiff of adulthood
indeed Hitler had been one of the first
20th century leaders to unmistakably
articulate quite a different youth value
of children in the aggressive fusion of
childhood and war
not long after World War one when many
teachers and military commanders still
frowned upon
boys early introduction to military
training Hitler wrote in meine Kumpf
of of the tactical objective to win over
the child he was convinced that anybody
who knew anything about the juveniles
spirit would know that youth always lend
a glad ear to rallying cries about what
it meant to be German for boys and
becoming a German mother for girls back
in Japan
soldiers memoirs for child leaders also
conveyed and now-familiar mimetic
repertoire of sentiments reiterating the
love ability of children on both sides
of the front line and the special bond
between these children and the
conquering soldiers in one such memoir
soldiers and children high Tyto Kodomo
from 1942 Moneta hero she wrote
touchingly about the children he had met
as a member of the imperial japanese
army appealing to the empathy of his
Japanese readers he related how some of
those children had lost their fathers or
mothers or both he noted that the world
had been turned upside down their
schools burned their house is gone he
who calls that he and his fellow
soldiers got along with them really well
played
with them gave them sweets and made them
laugh the fact that he identified how
the food and sweets had come from their
comfort bags further ingrained a direct
connection of similarity friendship or
shared responsibility between Japanese
children and those of the Empire after
all the children back home had helped
pack those bags by the same token the
good nature of the Japanese soldiers
along with their dignity and
righteousness is amplified via their
encounters not just with children
themselves but also with their positions
he no ashi Hey
famous right of war literature reports
in flower and soldiers hana tahiti 1939
how a ranking officer urges the respect
of children in their world quote do not
touch children's belongings at all if
there are any in the house will move
into tho we settle there this is just a
temporary boring of the houses of the
residents that is due to unavoidable
necessity we're by no means
appropriating these houses permanently
and when their owners come back we'll
have to return them at that time if a
family with a child should come back and
the child does not find his shoes socks
hat or toys how sad
will he be end of quote
importantly the children described in
discs accounts were never referred to as
enemies since such would have undermined
the premise of their needing protection
they stood outside the political realm
they were first and foremost innocent
and vulnerable children regardless of
the medium depictions of children were
almost always specifically anchored in
the notion indeed the emotion of
children is sweet vulnerable and
trusting creatures primed to incite
empathy in all viewers and readers
these assigned characteristics become
visible indeed imaginable because the
children these scenes cannot speak for
themselves the Japanese soldiers in
these scenes always encounter such
children alone without protection for
the child to become visible in the
historical record of war their families
must be seen to have failed to protect
them even if they're failing wasn't
being killed this is because the
intended effect of these portrayals the
imagining of an emotional bond between
children and soldiers requires that the
children's families be literally and
figuratively out of the picture but this
means the conquerors can be seen as
surrogate family and protectors absolved
of any guilt or shame of their conquest
the portrayals also imposed the notion
of childhood as universally innocent and
if children is already always worthy of
empathy of soldiers and readers alike at
the same time the fact that the scenes
help to normalize encounters between
children soldiers also distracted the
focus from and serve to reduce the
violence that preceded such seemingly
innocent relationships they help to
convey the notion that the soldiers of
the Japanese Imperial Army were good men
who intended only to protect and rescue
all children these images and narratives
transmuted war into an aesthetic and
rhetoric not of destruction but rescue
not of battle but peace not of chaos but
comforting order when soldiers were
portrayed as figuratively touching
children as embracing their childlike
innocence their gestures established
that they could connect with their own
childhood or at least that they
long to the forcefully repeatedly
conveyed notion of the universality of
childhood facilitated the notion the
children were already symbolically
united and were thus the natural
builders of peace the Japanese wartime
cultural machinations tying children to
the war effort were not unique of course
similar mechanisms were employed in war
and occupation settings around the world
nor did 1945 constitute a total rupture
in the cultivation of the emotions I
have described the new constitution in
1946 formed the basis of what later
became until only recently and
institutionalized and normalized
anti-militarism both occupation era
photography and soldiers reflections
quickly reconstituted the emotional
capital of children rather than being
enlisted in emotionalizing and
legitimizing Empire children were now
more than ever enlisted as embodiment of
peace and icons of humanitarianism Lisa
mokey has observed constructions of the
human in contemporary humanitarianism
that constructions of the human in
contemporary humanitarianism Center on
special observably standardized
representational uses of children in
registers with effective effective and
ritual efficacy yet as we have seen
these representational uses of children
are not an invention of the effects of
war but a part of the very fabric of
justifying war as occupation error
depictions of children and soldiers
assigned Japanese children's roles that
had previously been held by Asian
children in areas once occupied by the
Japanese Imperial
armie the Japanese publishers editors
writers illustrators and advertisers who
had helped militarized the realm of the
child made a perplexingly swift
turnabout about-turn I'm sorry
they fervently promoted how to turn
children into pacifists indeed back into
what now were claimed to be true
children necessarily oblivious to the
woes of post-war occupation as phrased
by a girl who had served in the him a
unique girls Corps a unit of female
students mobilized to the front in the
Battle of Okinawa quote finally I was
able to rid myself of military clothes
and be a girl again end of quote
the girl she wanted to return to was of
course both female no longer wearing
male soldiers clothing and a child
restored to innocence in this post-war
face two things occur actual children
become victims and children in
children's books become pacifists
American chocolate and chewing gum
become as welcome as pacifist
instruction including familiarity and
simple and sympathy towards their former
enemy especially the United States one
example is the 1946 English conversation
picture book kumkum English for
everybody on its cover a tall blond
American GI bends down to a Japanese boy
in a school uniform on the pages within
the boy talks to the American about
Japanese sights and society throughout
illustrations and narrative single
signal the New World Order manifested in
the shape of an irreversible
generational reconfiguration another
picture book published by Kodansha
America McGorry from 1948
turns to the universality of childhood
the book introduces American sights from
coast to coast and features everyday
scenes from grocery shopping to doing
laundry all described as if a tourist
guide for children the preface by SOB
Yuichiro the director of the public
relations division of Tokyo newspaper
emphasized the importance of today's
children understanding the real America
and while the cover is similar to
earlier wartime Kodansha picture books
which often included both a girl and a
boy from Japan proper and the colonies
it also signals a new political racial
and gender order while the boys facial
features are ambiguous the boys dark
hair suggests he could be Japanese and
while the girls strawberry blonde hair
leaves no doubt that she's American she
also holds a Japanese doll in her arm
Japan the big brother or even father to
Asians in the Empire has turned into a
younger brother of Miss America whose
right arm rests on the boy's shoulder
further emphasizing Japan's and the boys
junior status in this new relationship
and world in a crowning touch the
American flag flutters in the background
thank you
[Applause]
thank you for a wonderful presentation
not only in terms of your analysis but
these images are each one is a kind of
jam unto itself open the floor to
questions we have a pretty full room so
Kaitlin first speak a little bit of so a
lot of this seems to fit in nicely and
yet also somewhat clash with ideas about
a month in Japanese colonial discourse
about the construction of race in the
colonies of the idea of the Koreans and
the Taiwanese and Chinese as little
ethnicities where I'm sensing that that
seems to fit in with these depictions of
children as sort of the same as Japanese
but there's also something about the
discourse that maintains the difference
that is there always I look at the
materials that I've presented and
described as one variation on the kind
of theme you've just articulated the
point I was trying to make and I think
that holds throughout the first half of
the 20th century is that it really
depends on who the intended audience of
these materials is and how these
materials circulate in contrast to
materials that were produced for a
teenage audience for instance and for an
adult audience the one image I showed
where Japan is this huge figure and
other Asians in the Greater East Asia
co-prosperity fears are simply smaller
figures when can't even see them as
necessarily younger in terms of
generation but smaller figures in
ambiguous ways these are more interested
in the product these representations are
more interested to
go back and forth between leveling
difference and emphasizing difference
for the children I was and I'm
interested in and it's important I think
to not conflate children with teenagers
here because these are materials for
children that are largely written in
katakana so for either a very beginning
beginner reader or a non reader and so
for these children in particular the
emphasis is on we are all children we
have a shared set of characteristics and
these children are already always at
peace
they are already protected they are the
future peace builders so there's much
less in this material then in the
material for the next older age group
about yes and the next thing that will
happen is you will grow into a fierce
Japanese soldier it places these younger
children in a very particular way and
and also in a much more egalitarian way
place visa vie other Asians
I should note though I'm sorry to go on
I should note though that of course we
can't assume that readers actually read
according to the age group these things
were produced for and so of course
there's always a mix of we can assume
that adults read to the children or
older children read to the children but
looking at the material itself it is
somewhat distinct from materials
produced for other age groups
I was wondering the children ideological
decryption like you're acknowledging is
the kind of universal one so could you
elaborate on Japanese uniqueness on this
case particularly and also dramatized on
the creature empathize children's
innocence and really pure polity but do
you also say the counter examples such
as children are unruly dangerous does
require social engineering and control
I'm primarily a student of Japanese
culture so it's very hard to make
clear-cut statements about how the
Japanese case compares to other places
but I have looked at similar materials
during the occupation after the Second
World War in Europe for instance and one
of the things one a number of things one
can probably say with some certainty are
the following first of all the kinds of
images that I've shown here and the
kinds of rhetoric I've presented can be
found everywhere
so the difference does not line a Sara
Lee in the exact shape and aesthetics of
these representations but I believe it
lies in how prevalent these materials
were and so I used the example of Nazi
Germany where you can also find
representations of Hitler and his
leadership with little children in
similar kinds of formations were the the
sort of vulnerability and the cuteness
of the child is used to enhance the
humanity of the adult but it was much
less common in the German context
same with occupation era France for
instance mary-louise Roberts has found
that there were also postcards of German
soldiers with French children for
instance there are very similar
comparable accounts of actual soldiers
on all fronts including I have this very
nice example from a Russian medic that
marches into Berlin and she's recalling
all the horrors that the German
Wehrmacht has perpetrated in her home
and then she says and yet looking at
these Japanese sorry at these German
children I couldn't help but give them
the candy we had and things like that so
these things pop up in different
contexts but the one difference is how
prevalent they are and another
difference and I think Japan in that
sense is certainly fully exploiting this
potential to what degrees do they
exploit certain notions of the child and
of childhood and that's very different
in in Nazi Germany I think there's a
very very pronounced emphasis on even
little children like those you've seen
in these pictures of that age are really
just into getting away from that
childhood getting away from being
vulnerable and not quite mature enough
yet that's a very common reoccurring
image in the German context by the same
token to say one last word of course you
can find images propaganda posters with
Stalin with Mao with little kids on
their lab for instance but that's not
very commonly circulating in these
places to the degree I know hopefully
somebody else will do a serious job
somebody who actually reads those
languages
I've looked into it a little bit another
difference in the Japan case is of
course that you don't see the emperor
with children the emperor is not
interested for obvious reasons as you
all know in appearing particularly but I
do that it is really noted notable that
these are visual motifs that are also
connected to media and commodity forms
of capitals modernity and so on the one
hand yes to look at the particularity of
the Japanese Empire and I definitely
understand the the draw to France s Nazi
Germany as an ally for instance but I
wonder to what degree these are visual
motifs that are sticking to these
commodity and media forms and could be
said to be circulating globally also
France Britain the United States in a
way that is really about those commodity
and media cultures that are not
necessarily just maybe
was a wonderfully stimulating talk and
Q&A already at this point I have a
complex of questions let's let's see if
it makes it makes any sense when
listening to you're looking at the
images I was wondering what the
intentionality of the artists is what
the processes are by which they get by
their images too they copy from one
another is there something in the air
that they are bringing down on paper
whom are they imagining as their
audience and if it's in quite a verse
and the examples that you gave some
things may have been more for an adult
audience other things to be children's
images that I start children's books but
I wondered whether even with children's
books the artists imagined the adults
looking over the shoulders of the
children
one thing that did come to mind that
probably reads too much into the
evidence is that humans react very
strongly to the to the faces of children
in particular and I had enough by the
1930s this is much better understood
than before there's something disarming
about seeing a child's face it attracts
our attention immediately
and it would be fascinating if you have
materials that allow you to to
understand to what extent the artist was
strategizing and to what extent they
were just trying on lots of different
things or how subconsciously repeating
themes really worked now to broaden this
scale of questions even even further I
think your presentation raises the
question what is special about the mid
20th century and we searching my memory
for earlier images where children
well there might be early examples I
think in that kind of density and
consistency at least from my mind I
don't know if that tells us something
about the media environment perhaps
about the scale of materials being
produced for children or if there's
something about the particular
totalitarian wars the mid 20th century
we're reaching for the child as an image
reminds people that this is not just a
matter of two monarchs having a property
dispute but that's one question okay
I'll try what I what I can
first of all in in terms of the
intentionality of the artist I'm not
equipped to answer that question but
what as a product as a whole write a
children's book or a children's magazine
what that tells you and this is easy to
address is that intentionality was very
very explicit it's not something that
you know just emerges from the images
many of these children's books and
magazines books in particular had
something like a preface a call to
educators and mothers often to sensei
and and to the teachers and the mothers
the father's do not don't get singled
out precisely with the message that they
envision a particular book or a
particular story is supposed to convey
that said of course that doesn't exclude
the possibility that different kinds of
readers made different kinds of senses
of all of this and the reason why I or
one of the reasons why I'm so focused on
the emotionality of the child is
precisely because of course that's
not necessarily a message or not only a
message to other children right as we
know right
children are not particularly invested
in being vulnerable unless they want to
get something out of you sorry but so
it's not it's not the the main driving
sentiment of the child but so some of
these signals I think are really
intended for an adult reader or a reader
to the child but again on top of that
there were real directions on mothers
and to mothers and teachers that
essentially articulated that there's
nothing more important than to teach our
children certain kinds of things that
they hopefully will find in the pages
and in the pictures the question about
early 20th century specificity of the
ubiquitousness of ubiquity of children's
images I think is a very good
observation and and I think that has to
do partly with the previous question but
quite simply with the discovery of first
of all with the with the development of
media in general right there there's an
explosion of magazines an explosion of
children's books
the Japanese state discovers the thing
that is called homefront that actually
one needs to have at least passive
support of anybody at home if one is to
successfully conduct a long time term
war there are also of course artistic
possibilities but as you know a
children's books in magazines
were one of the last kinds of
publications that still were published
in color and and there was a reason for
that because of course the assumption
was the children would be more attracted
to color than to black and white kinds
of illustrations one other question that
I'm unsure whether you asked it or I'm
had it I thought about that when you
asked your question was about no I think
I forgot sorry people keep telling me it
will come back later but I don't know
whether that's true I'll try a few let's
try to just squeeze in very short
questions of soccer on two issues that I
was thinking about in your presentation
they also go back to your 2017 book and
one is about say now youth and the other
is about sports because it seems that
same youth category developed over that
same period as that's passage between
children and adults so I'm wondering to
what extent representations of seinen of
youth have the same kinds of sort of
symbolic load and effective qualities as
children these would be the war effort
and where children are sob and in sports
a New Britain yourself I mean appeared
in that same period particularly
important for saving for youth and
sports are different from us so
and some sports then played a role in
imagining both these these periods of
life but also their relationship to
character formation contributions you're
asking me whether there's a similar set
of how this category of youths a name
lates to children and whether they were
similar or different times of the
associations that you're talking about
here and whether and this week this
difference between sob and and support
meeting playing sports associated with
those two periods and again the use of
them representative Lee
so for sin and I think the core set of
images is quite different because you
see these older kids then for instance
in war games represented in war games
and there's much more emphasis on such
war games not being play not being mere
play there is a distinction between war
games is just being fun and being sort
of a nice pastime and war games that are
meant to actually train and educate
young boys in particular to become
soldiers and you see this both in
writings of course of teachers for
instance but also of military
instructors military instructors did go
into schools to to train boys in
marching information rifle practices and
so on and so forth but also in
representation so for the younger
children for instance you would have
relatively wild formations of children
being all over the place preferably with
a puppy you know a very cute little dog
doing you know playing with self-made
kinds of toys and
weapons whereas for seinen and then
older teenagers in general the emphasis
is very much on likening these boys and
their games to the actual soldiers so
you would have Imperial Army soldiers
with some fire or bombed like
illustration on the cover and then all
kinds of writings and images of boys in
terms of I can't believe you're asking
me about sob and sports since that's
your field of expertise
but in the in the work in the writings
and images of war games that I've looked
at sports doesn't come up at all it's
not the kind of sort of casual
understanding I would normally have that
some sports are sort of like military
training or our casual understanding
that the some sports take on some of the
characteristics or do some of the
socialization work that militaries might
do in some other context sport is not
part of that war game picture properly
partly because even in the few images
that you saw of relatively young boys of
marching in the schoolyard for instance
it's military the teachers are there
right they are present but it's military
who makes them march and there's no
sense that this is fun for the children
at the same time there are also maneuver
type war games of thousands of children
orchestrated in the 1930s and 40s often
modeled in some fashion on Imperial Army
maneuvers and some children report that
that was fun
but from the
from the perspective of the instructors
and the teachers they had no interest in
you know putting sports and and these
kinds of trainings in in one field so to
speak thank you for a fascinating talk
and I think I particularly found your
presentation of like the varied
assemblages of children's use value to
be fascinating not just for the breadth
and diversity of the values themselves
but I guess the differences that you've
noted between the Japanese use cases and
Germany and Hitler for example but in
line with the use values that you've
assigned to particularly in this talk to
young children I did have a question in
your work thus far with this material
have you marked or noticed shifts either
ships or phases within the primary uses
of these I guess use values throughout I
guess the total war mobilization towards
the end of the war I think you just
touched upon it in your last answer a
little bit but the reason why I asked is
particularly with your emphasis on the
use of children's media along this
development magazines and books and
whatnot in particular media pops into my
head specifically within the media
development of animation you mentioned
formal title before but the 1945 release
of Momotaro Cimino shinbei which was
specifically targeted at children and
comes completely if not even further in
line with the use value of children that
you
with Hitler right thumb children in that
in that film are specifically targeted
directly as soldiers not just children
their play is equated with jumping off a
tree onto America this idea of preparing
for an invasion
there's an interesting analogue to
education but since we're out of time I
will be bad on the other side but I was
just wondering if you saw any major
shifts or I guess primary phases of
development throughout this type of use
value escape
I think the shift is not so much in
terms of the time line that you're
looking at then across different age
groups momotaro
there's a reason why Momotaro comes in
1945 I mean in terms of this timeline
right you have comics before that Nora
Kudo for instance and if you wanted to
somebody did if you wanted to do a study
of how Nora kudo appears over the 20 or
so 25 years it it was published there is
of course a transformation of the
character from something much more
benign and clueless to somebody more
focused and militaristic but overall in
terms of the bulk of the material I've
looked at I don't think one can speak of
a trend towards the moment of momotaro
[Applause]
[Music]